with more reaction the author of the
best-selling book the case against
impeaching Trump Harvard Law Professor
Alan Dershowitz and Fox News contributed
Tammy Bruce you know I know that Senator
Grassley Tammy's given every
consideration private-public everything
move the day from Monday to wednesday
etc I do believe that Judge Cavanaugh
should go second to respond to his
accuser of course but my advice to the
Senate Judiciary Committee tonight is
this give them the extra day sure 24
hours if that's what they're asking for
10 o'clock tomorrow night fine give them
another 24 hours but this has to be the
last time oh yeah I don't know what
really the drama is for another 24 hours
if they need it that's fine she's known
at least certainly that this process was
started all the way back in July she has
been in control of this timeline from
the beginning if this had been handled
properly when senator Feinstein had this
letter we wouldn't be at these kinds of
deadlines because this could have been
addressed through the natural process
the the request she made also would
literally set up an actual kangaroo
court where you change the rules the
principles the process of a court
hearing or just a hearing in general
when you're dealing with accusations
like this and clearly it's it's absurd
when you see those demands it almost
seemed as though they wanted them to be
rejected so that they could say the
committee didn't want to hear I'm told
that as the Democratic strategy and so
many Democrats professor they have
already said they believe HAARP the
censored it's absurd for anybody to say
at this point I believe her or I believe
him or I don't believe her I don't
believe him we haven't heard them we
haven't seen the evidence you know
people aren't born with a sex-linked
gene for honesty or dishonesty some
women lie some women tell the truth some
men lie some men tell the truth
the one thing that there should be no
compromise on in every civil libertarian
and every Democrat should demand she
must go first you know the tool of the
Inquisition was to always call the
accused first make him testify mayhem
lay out his whole case and
only then tell him what the accusations
are yours is accusing you you know it's
you probably gotta scare the living
daylights that you agree with me as much
as you do lately but I am a similar
Bavarian apart everything okay oh I know
but this is this is too serious to me I
do believe so I'm urging the Republicans
to give the extra day but all these
Democrats have made up their mind if any
Republican had said professor Dershowitz
I believe him you and I both know there
would be a very different reaction in
this country and they've said it they
said it when it comes to the newly
elected Attorney General keith Ellison
they're not opening up an investigation
as to him and there is very credible
evidence look we can't have one truth
for Republicans one truth for Democrats
one process for Republicans one process
for Democrats we all have to pass the
shoe on the other foot test I asked
myself what if this were a liberal
Democrat who were nominated by a liberal
president what would I be demanding
exactly the same as what I'm here
handing now due process civil liberties
the rule of law if I could just add that
if people who are thinking that by
giving this extra day or accommodating
even more is going to change what the
Democrats say after he is confirmed they
are wrong no matter what happens the
rhetoric and the argument will be the
same is that the GOP are misogynists and
they're racists and it won't matter what
you do at this stage they simply must do
the right thing
Huffington Post poll found that on the
issue of credibility of the accuser
which is what I was afraid of was that
about 25 percent of women found her
credible and 28 percent of men found her
credible but so the majority the vast
majority of people aren't believing her
because of this charade that has been
unfolding in front of us that we've got
to get on with the country's business
they've got to take that seriously
because there's no appeasing the people
who are behind this but she got a full
opportunity to make her case and she has
to be given a full opportunity also
have witnesses subpoenaed judge the
other man anybody else who was there
they have to be given the opportunity to
testify as well and especially all those
people that have spoken out in favor of
Professor Cavanaugh no Liam in high
school in college and law school in the
Bush administration or women that
offended concedes that he worked for him
86 years is a long time
he needs to be heard and I think
everybody breakfast if you have real
lawyers permission you both are fair
senators that's the fair don't rush to
judgment due process presumption of
innocence this is core to who we are as
a country back up thank you both